tens of thousands of Junior doctors in
England have begun a three-day strike
over pay and working conditions in the
country's National Health Service they
make up around 40 percent of the medical
Workforce in the UK Al jazeera's Nadine
barber joins us now from outside guys
Hospital in London the name what are the
strikers main demands
well Adrian they have various demands
but the main one the huge one is pay I
should point out to viewers that Junior
doctors is a label applied to people who
have just qualified from medical school
right up to people who have maybe 10
years of experience and are
neurosurgeons or people running whole
departments responsible for hundreds of
patients on a shift so it's quite varied
and they say their their Union the
British Medical Association says that
since 2008 the failure of pay to keep
Pace with inflation means they've had a
real terms pay cut of 26 percent so what
they're asking the government for is a
rise of 35
right now the current payoff Earth pay
rise of eight percent over four years
that they've had ends this month they
say they are desperate and that their
profession is in Dire Straits that's
because those pay the real terms pay
cuts is pushing people out of the job
they're saying that people who are very
uh highly experienced or qualified
Medics are leaving for places like
Australia where they can a much more
money they're saying also that that's
creating extra strain on them they're
having to work longer hours under more
pressure and they simply are being
driven to do this strike which is over
three days
um they say that the government can
afford it they're disputing what the
government says uh the cost will be the
government says it can't go anywhere
near what they want it will be
inflationary and also simply the numbers
don't add up so there is an ampas and
the government on Friday night suddenly
said we're willing to talk on pay if you
call off the strike the union says
that's not reasonable other health
unions have actually paused their
industrial action recently to enter
negotiations lady thanks indeed Nadine
barber they're live at guys Hospital uh
the guys and Thomas Hospital in in
London Andrew myosin is a doctor who
campaigns for more investment in public
health
I'm Dr Andrew Meyerson I am an NHS a e
doctor I originally from the United
States and I came to the United Kingdom
about seven years ago to study medicine
and I decided to stay here because I
love the NHS we've seen you know a 30
reduction in our real terms pay in the
last 15 years basically it means that
for a quarter of the Year from you know
September to December we're working for
free and that's a big issue that's a
huge issue for staff retention that's
why so many people are burning out we're
seeing ads for you know come to work in
Australia come to work in New Zealand
you know and we're seeing a lot of our
colleagues who are taking you know those
offers to work in much better conditions
with much better pay down under because
it's just it's it's just becoming too
difficult to work in the NHS right now
every every winter is a bad winter for
the for the NHS and for the last 10
years we every single winter we've been
complaining to the government things are
getting worse waiting times are getting
worse people are coming to harm and they
are being extraordinarily successful in
driving people away from the from the
public system into a you know into a
two-tier system where people that can
afford it wealthy people they can go see
private private uh clinicians and but
the rest of everybody else is left to
suffer a good shift nowadays for so many
a e staff is one where you know nobody
dies in our waiting room or dies you
know on the back of an ambulance every
time I you know I I see a patient I have
to apologize for the terribly long wait
that they're enduring and you know and
and I speak to them honestly about you
know the difficulties that we're facing
that we don't have enough staff we don't
have enough resources and so you know we
we don't want to go on strike nobody
wants to go on strike but when you know
for every single year we are we are
screaming to the government do something
and they don't listen then this is what
it's come to when I've gone to to picket
lines to uh to support you know whether
it's ambulance Crews or nurses it is
incredibly invigorating as horrific as
the situation is right now with so many
people dying
um getting through the pandemic and
seeing the horrors that we've we've been
through and feeling so awful and and
despairing so much about the state of
the NHS this is the one thing that's
actually giving me hope